- [Narrator] This is
Cami, a red ruffed lemur.
Her world is small, and
it's shrinking daily.
(eclectic music)
The red ruffed lemur comes
by its name, honestly.
It's covered in a brilliant chestnut coat.
The rest of its body, its
face, hands, belly, and tail
are a deep black.
Of the hundreds of species
of lemur in Madagascar,
the red ruffed lemur is
one of the most endangered.
Found only on a single
peninsula in the north west
of the island country the
rainforests the red ruffed lemur
call home are also highly valued
for the beautiful rosewood
and ebony trees that grow there.
It's in the canopy of these
that you can find these lemurs.
There they search for
fruit, which makes up
nearly their whole diet.
Their home forests are being
harvested at an alarming rate,
taking the red ruffed lemur's
chance of survival with them.
Conservationists estimate
that there are only
three to 5,000 left in the wild.
This is the red ruffed lemur.
(eclectic music)